[Music]
just biscuits you've done it all Rosie
what makes you so terrific anyway it's
my lifestyle mr. J I'm to be
user-friendly remember Rosie the robot
on the Jetsons well she offered an
entertaining view of the Space Age but
some of the biggest names in technology
like Amazon's Jeff Bezos and PayPal
co-founder Peter Thiel are donating
millions to explore something that also
seems out of this world the possibility
of eternal life
yep the search for the science and tools
to keep our lives going inspired Stanley
bings new novel it's called immortal
life assumed to be true story think
about that for a second
imagines a future where humans evolved
in digital form Stan Lee Bing by the way
is the pen name of Gil Schwartz Gil is a
senior executive vice president and
chief communications officer for the CBS
Corporation immortal life is published
by Simon & Schuster which is a division
of CBS but for the purpose of this
interview we're going to call you
Stanley you may call me Beyonce okay
this is the thing when I read this book
I don't know if your intention was to
scare us or to make us think because it
involves body transplants and brain
transplants and this is a big departure
for you why was this subject so
fascinating no first of all it involves
people who have a lot of money and
they're in business and they have never
failed at anything these Silicon Valley
types and and they are looking into the
possibility of essentially copying your
brain doing a if you think of the brain
as a computer you can backup your brain
you put it in a storage unit and then if
you can create a new housing for it then
you've got a new body and this could be
done infinitely fascinates you about
that I I'm you know I'm not as young as
I used to be and and I would like to
live forever and I think a lot of people
when they get to the age you could be 40
and suddenly you realized well you know
what it would be really nice to line
extend my life a hundred years right the
idea being that your personal device
could be implanted into your brain and
the
you could live immortally once the birth
once the body essentially dies well
what'd you do well the body the your old
body may die but you probably can create
a new one right I mean right now all
your knowledge would be in this which
can be transplanted and at least it can
be it can be sent it can be sent up to
the cloud the cloud can hold it and then
it can come down and then the question
is how do you get the new body and we're
right now printing you know organs
kidneys are being printed they're not
working yet but if you move the world 20
years 25 years into the future it's easy
to see how you might be able to create
life by printing it yeah and then you
have a new body and I think you know I'm
feeling pretty good but if somebody
offered me a brand new body right off
you know at one point there was a
printer of a 3d penis I'm thinking what
is he trying to say here well it's
certainly an organ oh my no homo no homo
who does print that does appreciate I
mean yes one follow on that I mean one
one reviewer of this book did call it an
optimistic nightmare yeah and another
called it a dystopian satire yeah I know
that's both of them I'll accept you know
well I like the fact that it's scary I
mean I think some of the best I think
some of the best entertainments that we
have especially ones thinking about you
know how the world is going it should be
a little scary and what you're talking
about is transplanting a consciousness
from one person into a body that has its
own consciousness I mean our hero genes
he's not very bright and his brain a
newly created gene gene wants to live
and here comes this massive
consciousness of this hundred and twenty
seven year old mogul pouring into his
head yes and that's uncomfortable yeah
that should be that should be scary and
I think by the way you don't have to be
in the future to be scared about the
world great you dedicate this book to
the tech Titans right of the world just
have Mark Zuckerberg Elon Musk Larry
Ellison I think about Google now
approaching its 20th years yes your
mantra do no evil work and we're
at this point of technology whether it's
intentional or not becoming involved in
some really questionable activities with
regards to elections what have you
social media hmm what role do you see
technology having in the future is it
more of a positive thing or as you said
it parts of it are scary in this well I
think the problem of Technology is not
in itself I mean they do a lot of good
things the the problems happen when
people do tech because they can in other
words they made bombs because it was so
interesting to figure out how do you do
that a nuclear power plants you know wow
we could do that let's try to do that
now the tech guys are doing a lot of
stuff like for me self-driving cars
they'll be able to do it do you want it
do you you I don't want one I really
like a big car with horsepower my and
and my feeling about self-driving cars
is no one will be able to drive their
car it has to be everybody in line all
going and you know you'll be doing in
that self driven car what you'll be
connecting with the clouds through your
implanted yeah yeah so it's just like
not creating human beings you take did
you take the sailing you take us on such
a fantastical ride because you said he's
127 years old person in the book is 60 I
like very much I do 10 that his empire
is 63 trillion dollars where did you get
the a $10,000 bathrobe where did you get
these figures from well I live in New
York at the time and you know you go to
have breakfast and it's $40 more times
the u.s. GDP sixty-three trillion I like
it women are heroes in this book oh yes
they are absolutely they saved the plan
Lee Bing thank you
they save a lot of people thank you so
much immortal life is on sale today